from the day you got fired
how many days prior to that was when you
questioned hillary clinton oh i think it
was four i think i questioned her on a
thursday and lost my job
on a sunday oh i didn't know that so so
four days after you
you questioned hillary clinton so what
happened there was and i've spoken about
this with um you know
sunny recently that we were like no one
really understood what happened there
and i don't know if it's attributed to
the hillary clinton interview i really
don't i have no idea what year was that
was it 16 17. it's right around there
she was right no running back
or after she lost no no she was it was
after she lost after she lost she wrote
a book called what happened it was the
first live appearance she did on the
view and she asked the question oh yeah
that's right i saw that yeah i asked the
question i had i had just re-upped like
that summer you know you had to like i
said they had to renew you even though
you had a three-year contract they had
to renew you so i signed the paperwork i
was like okay i guess i'm in for another
year and that's the way i view this
business you never know you could be out
tomorrow you know so i was like okay in
for another year
i asked what i thought was a pretty
benign question i asked her i said
listen you know you're saying you're
acting like you're surprised that trump
won but it sounds a little tone deaf to
me because i was talking to people
around the country who were disgusted
with a lot of what was going on like
looking back do you see that maybe these
people voted because they they didn't
like what was happening in the prior
administration i thought that was a
pretty fair question
her face said otherwise i didn't even
get to ask about her emails which was
really what i would it was a little bit
of panic at the show that day because i
was like well can we show here that she
signed a piece of paper that said she
knows what these classifications mean
and she's denied that she knew them but
share her signature and they were like i
wouldn't do that i wouldn't do that
there was a little bit of worry that it
was going to be combative
but don't they like that is that like
the whole point of the view they don't
want to tell you no i think the
perception is that but actually i think
there's a lot of protection that goes on
on shows like that for political figures
for point of views
so i didn't get to that but i asked the
tone-deaf question and then four days
later i actually got a call from someone
who worked in media i think i think it
was oliver darcy actually if i'm not
mistaken who wrote who called me and was
like there's a rumor that like megan
mccain's taking your job and i was like
oh well that can't be i just i was like
what and i wrote my producer and he was
like oh we'll get on it pr i don't even
think the ep of the show knew
no one knew the ep of this so this came
from the highest this came from super
this is not ep
no and my eps like candy and brian were
like
really quite nice to me and were like
listen
i don't know and i believed them and i
still believe them because they're i
really do um
so i don't know what happened i don't
know if it's related to that i don't
know if that was the icing on the cake i
don't know if there were talks going on
and then suddenly someone decided oh
great and also that interview didn't
help i don't really know just the timing
seemed so awesome so when did you when
did you sign the next year what
was in the summer
summer how many like weeks or months
before the hillary clinton uh uh
it was in august i don't remember it was
several weeks before that oh so so this
is fresh so you sign it's not like it's
six months no no several weeks it was
several weeks got it so they had already
committed to having you on for another
year yeah so it wasn't like behind
closed doors they were talking to megan
listen i maybe for all i know i mean
there are people that have since been
fired from there that were doing pretty
horrible things that's come out in the
news um
who i think probably were being
underhanded about it in many ways i
don't know i don't know what
conversations were and weren't going on
i just
it kind of changed my perception of
media because i always felt like a
contract was a contract and all of a
sudden i realized which was helpful for
the future like
okay you're here today you could be gone
tomorrow so just keep that in mind some
people would say just be happy you're
sitting here because maybe you pissed
off the wrong person you know because
there's certain people in politics you
don't piss off because they have a
reputation you know that's right and
that reputation is a multi-dimensional
type of a reputation if you know what
i'm talking about everyone off so i'm in
bad shape maybe i'll come work here you
know
but we would love you so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you